yo tout le monde sait squeeze et on se
retrouve en ce jeudi soir sur un nouveau
jeu de merde alors oui c'est ric hochet
j'avais fait un podcast dessus vous
pouvez aller le voir en cliquant sur la
vidéo qui apparaît en gros maintenant je
vous laisse un délai de cinq secondes
pendant lequel je vais chanter la
marseillaise
voilà alors c'est parti on teste le jeu
tout de suite fan serrures alors déjà on
peut noter une amélioration
il y à 14 serveurs alors qu'au moment de
la vidéo il y en avait que cet os est un
jeu de folie est en fait vous allez voir
que le jeu n'est pas si nul que ça
puisque quand on prend un milliardième
de milliardième de milliardième de gray
on pourrait éventuellement rigoler alors
comment ça je suis mort j'étais en train
de jouer à mais je suis en train de
jouer passer ça comme ça chez moi
j'étais encore en train de jouer cette
animation est totalement nulle
voilà comme ça oui oui et je leur dédie
ce matin au quai faire tomber l'autre
tiens tiens à merde à une barrière qui
protège tient aux bâtards ouais je te le
disent certains titres y avait encore le
bruit tiens tiens homme gentil si bam
boum j'anticipe gentil gentil gentil si
bon aller mais c'est nul ce jeu-là aux
ricochets et là on ne blague le jeu
s'appelle décrocher c'était une blague
et commence à plus tard boudin dans
trois secondes 2 1
oh [ __ ] il a tapé leskiw à je lui
tiens tiens des coûts de 10 dans papa
ouais je pars vu avec attendez je peux
l'avoir en tirant là dedans c'est
excellent mathémat et messieurs je mets
ce joli est en fête géniale mais il fait
quoi mais qu'est ce qui fait de la route
oh oh oh non mais ça n'est jamais
regardé l'eau mais non non c'est pas
juste
mais en fait le jeu il est trop bien
ils vont passer plus bas de caisse
énorme tiens tiens on faisait bien
viande vient là vient la tient mais pour
toi le disque mais la dynamo kia moi je
viens me voir en face daoues aux os il
s'est suicidé au il est trop nul
oh attendez technique du tricheur en
vente mais son mouvement un tout petit
peu à droite
yes yes on t'a le pitch ou une 4e botté
par squeeze aux îles afin salto vous
avez fait non mais c'est pas possible
c'est des modules et pourquoi je joue
plus mais je veux jouer mais laisse moi
jouer pourquoi j'ai plus le droit de
jouer moi
what the fuck d'argent nos médecins ne
veulent pas de moi je m'en fous je
rejoins luxe arbre alors la [ __ ] façon
il y en a plein allez on pourra
rejoindre celui là on va rigoler un coup
ou une nouvelle map s'il vous plaît
il y aura même des sons de quake trop
bien c'est parti les faits en ce sens
aux houillères alors wa al battar farid
merde en le sac à merde autant m moi
j'aborde l ail et cette fois il ya deux
étages c'est un puzzle game un jeu
rebondit ouais pouces tient pas bam toi
je te suis donc se taire car mr avec
pommes de terre tomates en battant nancy
mawn choc ici à les horaires de geek
très précis - sur le genre cette partie
là moi je dis ça je dis rien mais je
tiens tiens tu casses toi tu en bâtard
abattent arme et je vais la voir mais
[ __ ] mais ils sont trop forts
tin les mecs mais ils se cassent un
coureur c'est une pop
oui oui je vais la voir alors toi mon
gars alors toi mon gars tu es mort aux
bâtards
en fait faut jamais les sujets trop
qu'on sait qu'on va camper sur une bonne
plateforme va camper ici on l'attend et
relatant up qui sont ils songent va bien
tiens tiens oui oh oui
accor monte à défoncer au common tola
olalala on mettait les lèvres par un
chasseur quoi oh là là là c'était
magnifique et regardez le regarder le on
aussi pour notre futur je dis ça je
tiens j'ai fait des ricochets palop pour
l'afrique aussi disponible c'est quoi
cette tenue ils sont crus dans stargate
en 1960 ou quoi bon le jeu disponible
pour un ou deux mais pas pas sur steam
j'espère que cette mini vidéos vous aura
plu on se retrouve demain pour une vidéo
qui tue sa mère sur devil may cry avec
notre rêve tout bordel et je vous laisse
sur monique pas sûr hôtesse de caisse
sur tout le monde puisse à bientôt